for me i've only ever been with athletes
and like the culture that's set for them
like they're not allowed to process
their emotions in that way it's like it
causes it it makes it builds up a wall
for them because it's like if they show
emotion in that way they're weak and
that's what they've been told their
whole life like you cry you're [ __ ] to
me when a man when a man cries and like
well depends what they're crying about
but like that's like vulnerable and like
to me that strength you're able to
because there is such a culture like you
know oh don't be a don't be a [ __ ] like
that's what they'll say to like men yeah
like don't be a pupsy and like also like
that's kind of [ __ ] on on the flip
side so a common complaint i hear from
guys is women say they want the
emotional side from us like they say
they want us to cry in front of them
they say they want it but then we give
it to them and they're not attracted to
it and they don't like it so women don't
really know what they want